all right everyone I think we're ready
to get started so thank you for coming
out so early in the morning after a
party I appreciate it this talk I hope
will be interesting and all you can
always fall asleep if you find it too
boring it's called four languages and 40
years ago I'm stop Russian all so what
can we learn from the 1970s 1970s a long
time ago in this still some interesting
things that we haven't really caught up
with them I have a web shop when a
website f-sharp fun and profit comm so
all of our F sharp but I'm also
interested in all sorts of other
languages and I will hope to explain why
so this is the 1970s this is a photo
taken back then as you can see it was a
very ancient period and amazingly I am
so old that I was actually alive in the
1970s that's me
down in the corner there so yes there's
a family photo right here so 40 years
ago it's a long time ago but I think
there's a lot a lot of things we can
learn from them so I'm going to talk
about four maybe five languages I'm
going to start with a brief history of
programming languages and then I'm going
to talk about hammers and toolkits and
why not everything is a hammer and then
I'm going to talk about my four
languages and maybe my fifth name which
X from 1979 and you'll have to guess
where that is okay so let's start with a
brief history this is one of my favorite
quotes a language that doesn't affect
the way you think about programming is
not worth knowing and as I talked about
various languages I'm going to give them
the galaxy brain seal of approval and
that means that this language if you
learn this language it will make your
head explode so that's good learning a
language that doesn't make your head
explode is a waste of time basically
right so back in the 1950s the
Precambrian era there weren't even
dinosaurs there we had nothing but
assembly languages and then towards the
end of the 50s
thought-trend sort of called down to the
water and made its appearance and it was
the first high-level language and so it
gets the galaxies brain because it
completely changed the way people
thought about programming you didn't
have to use per machine assembly code
and then cobol came out after that that
was the first enterprise language as we
all know lisp came out after that and
this gets a galaxy brain just for
existing because Lisp is the perfect
language we all know that this P is the
perfect language and has always been the
perfect language for ever and ever and
if you're interested in Y in knowing why
Lisp is not the dominant language today
you might read a very excellent essay
called worse it's better you can you
find that on the internet so ok in the
60s it was all about IBM and the seven
dwarfs which were the seven other tiny
companies can be an IBM and the first
important language of the 60s was
alcohol and alcohol was incredibly
important language it's basically the
foundation of all modern imperative
languages so if you use C or Pascal or
any of them modern languages you can
thank angle for that very very
influential basic came along the idea of
beginner's water concepts Pier one came
along this is meant to be the kind of
bastard child of Fortran and Algol and
it's meant to be the only language
you'll ever need so that's famous last
words of course because people don't use
Pier one except your parent Lee you can
actually get a dotnet and implementation
of Pier one if you need it so I swam
1966 this is it was never actually
implemented it was written up in a paper
but it's the most influential language
that was never actually implement it's
sort of like a Velvet Underground album
you know nobody read the paper but the
people who did me the paper went away
and created their own programming
languages it's the parent of all
functional programming languages and
it's the first language to use
indentation their scope so if you use
Python or Haskell or F sharp you can
thank her this language for that APL
1966 a long time ago is the first right
only language famous for that
and actually seriously the point of the
language was the idea is you think in
symbols if you're a mathematician you
think in symbols so you should write the
code in symbols and the notation was
actually as an aid to thought it was a
very well thought out language and he
actually got a Turing Award for
inventing it so it's actually we
shouldn't dump on APL is actually a very
important language so I'm going to give
it a galaxy brain if you could learn a
PL you definitely going to have your
mind blown
I'm similar 67 first language with
classes and inheritance Matz was talking
about this in his keynote so that will
also change the way people thought about
programming it broadly wouldn't blow
your galaxy brain today because you are
used to this kind of stuff but the time
was pretty impressive BCPL is important
because it's the first language of curly
braces so you can blame you can blame
BCPL for everything else and it's the
grandparent of C so that's a long time
ago it's 1937 that's 50 years something
like that
logos so logo was amazing because the
idea is you should have a programming
language for children to use now this is
when people still have mainframes so the
idea that you'd have young children
programming a computer was really a
pretty profound idea very very
insightful alcohol 68 the successor to
Algol another influential language very
very complex never really took off that
was very influential and that brings us
to the 70s which is the decade I'm
really gonna be talking about and then
the 70s a lot of things happened pretty
much everything that we can think of as
modern programming happened in the 1970s
so I call this the Cambrian explosion
lots of new programming languages lots
of new programming paradigms starting
with fourth so forth is the first in
captive language that definitely blows
your mind if you've ever used fourth
galaxies brain for fourth and there's a
book called of thinking fourth which I
highly recommend reading it's all about
designing programs in a modular way and
that's where the word factoring as in
refactoring came from Pascal 1970 that
was really Al Gore a nicer version of
alcohol for the rest of us see came out
in 1972 you've probably heard of that
one
still going strong prologue so this is
I'm going to talk about prologue a new
paradigm logic programming mind blowing
okay
1972 and it still still hasn't really
most people aren't really aware of it
email came out in 1973 another new
paradigm functional programming another
mind blowing a way of thinking about
programming sequel came out in 1974
another new paradigm relational database
programming and that's mind-blowing
again completely different way of
thinking about how you might interact
with a computer that people hadn't
really ever thought about before CLU is
worth a mention they introduced abstract
data types and so on very influential
written by Barbara Liskov and her team
and so if you've heard of the Liskov
substitution principle that is named
after her scheme came out there's
another list for the rest of us people
who don't like Common Lisp like scheme
myself basic came out and that was
amazing because you could actually
program a personal computer you'd like
the original I'll tear you had a flipped
little switches and with basic you could
actually do some your programming which
is amazing small talk came out and
that's a another mind-blowing layer
along with Lisp and small talk about C's
the two most influential languages I
would say all sorts of stuff came out
small talk and I will be spending a lot
of time on small talk a lot of people
say it's a real our language not not
like Simula and not like in Java and so
on we will see I will talk about oo in a
minute the other interesting thing about
small talk is the X practitioners of
small talk on a further influential gang
of four patents book have small talk as
one of the languages Kent Beck from XP
was it X small talk er the law the agile
people with X small talkers Martin
Fowler of refactoring Fame was an XML
talker so they really have infiltrated
the modern world of programming module 2
I'm just going to give this an honorable
mention it's sort of golang of the 1970s
it had a great module system had a great
covert eens I had all sorts of cool
stuff but never really took off
unfortunate but it was a very cool
language still still
riku language today and it was designed
for doing operating systems not just
high-level stuff in language x from
november 79 I think just squeaks under
the wire and I'm not really going to
tell you what it is except that it's the
grandparent of the most popular
programming language ever so that gives
you a clue and you can think about what
that is so and that definitely changed
the way people thought about programming
too right so if you look at the most
important programming paradigms you have
the imperative thing really implemented
by Al Gore and not really changed much
since object-oriented similar and small
talk functional programming started with
ml symbolic programming started with
lists' but really kind of took off in
the 70s with Mac Lisp and scheme and so
on logic programming Prolog in the 1970s
snack based programming fourth and 1970s
what's interesting is all these
paradigms really solidified by the late
70s and early 80s and these are the
paradigms we still use today and we
really haven't progressed that much I
mean there are some new things in in
programming technology as things like
pure functional programming like Haskell
and Erlang and so on but you know most
of us don't even understand this set of
paradigms let alone you know so I would
just encourage people to catch up with
the 1980s ok catch up with a 1980 state
of the art programming that would be a
fantastically useful thing just right
there so here's a toolkit if you do some
crafts frost mischief around the house
you know you obviously have a hammer for
having nails for screwing things in you
probably use a hammer for cutting wood
you probably want to use a hammer for
that and for tightening bolts you want
to use a hammer right is that true no of
course it's not true
so think about programming ok you know
you have lots of different things you do
when you do programming you do domain
modeling and you maybe use a hammer and
then to implement complex business rules
maybe you want to use a hammer and for
doing complex data queries you want to
use a hammer and for doing live coding
and stuff you want either hammer know
exactly the same thing applies you
should be using the right two
for the job and many of us only know one
tool we only have hammers and I'm just
wanting this talk I really want to
encourage you to go out and figure out
how to use a screwdriver and a saw and a
wrench you know so if you look at the
most popular programming languages all
right these are all the ones that you've
all heard of they're all basically the
same language and this is you know you
think all they're slightly different
they're subtly different but you don't
get a galaxy brain for learning Java if
you know C sharp or go or Visual Basic
they're really all the same language I
mean it's like if I said oh I speak
three languages I'm a real polyglot you
know I speak British English and I speak
American English and I speak Australian
English no I don't speak three languages
I mean yeah they're slightly different
there they're dialects you know but you
don't get a galaxy brain for speaking
three dialects of English you know if
you really want to make your head hurt
you know go and learn an African
language or an Asian language or a
Native American language they will make
your head explode learning different
dialects of British is not going to make
your head explode
so it's a big world out there please go
and explore it not every language has to
look like C C sharp Java and JavaScript
right so let's go exploring let's start
with our first language is just sequel
now most people are very familiar with
sequel it seems really boring but I
think there's some cool things that we
can get from sequel if we look at it
with some fresh eyes you know so first
of all it is actually originally perhaps
sequel not SQL and it was part of the
first relational database it was sort of
a proof of concept relational database
systems now before you had sequel you
had a dark ages where everyone had an
entire tree API and all the databases
had different ways of talking to them
and you had to use different things each
time very complicated and sequel really
got rid of this I mean the idea of you
know having different database API and
they know was crazy and sadly and
whistle from them going back to that a
little bit but you know sequel is a
fantastic step forward so what can we
learn from sequel well the first thing
is it's got a consistent model
everything is relation so we've got
tables which is a set of rows
here's some people with ages and here's
some parent-child relationships
everything is a relation everything is a
well a set of rows so when you do
something like select the name from a
table that's a projection and that gives
you back another set or if you do a
filter and you filter by age that gives
you back another set so no matter what
you do whether you project to your
projection or you do a filter whatever
you're always getting another set of
rows so it's absolutely consistent model
and what's cool about a consistent model
is its predictable so if we solve it if
you tell me that this system uses set
based operations and it's like oh yeah
you can do this kind of thing you can do
this kind of thing and I say well that's
interesting you since there's a set
based thing I bet they can do Cartesian
products right and then you say yeah
here you go
join so even without knowing anything
about sequel the fact that they can you
know fact this is set based thing
charters are they have something to do
Cartesian products because it's
predictable I would predict just the
fact they have a consistent model that
they'll do that so anytime we don't have
consistency it makes it really hard to
predict what's going on so if you ever
design the system try and make the
system consistent and makes it easier
for the people going to use it now
another thing about sequel which is not
necessarily obvious to people is it's an
expression based language so what do I
mean by an expression what I mean is
that everything you everything you do
return something so when you do a query
like this it returns a set right now
because it returns something you can
embed it as a sub query in a bigger one
and you can take this query and embed it
in a bigger sub query so because it
returns things the expression based
languages are composable kind of like
Lego you can take two pieces of Lego and
leave them to make a bigger piece of
Lego you can take to sequel statements
and glue them together to make a bigger
sequel expressions so expressions are
great expression based languages you can
do this in a statement based language
like C sharp and Java you can't do this
that they're not composable there's
another reason which expressions are
really nice and that is because they
don't have as many problems not as many
potential
as statement based languages so I'm
going to switch to this kind of a see
like language to demonstrate here's some
see like code what kinds of things can
go wrong with this okay so we have a
results variable and the thing is it's
initialized before it's actually
assigned to so we have to decide what
are we going to neutralize it to or
maybe we forget to initialize it you
know that's a problem and what about if
we forget to assign it in the middle of
the if statement so one of the branches
now obviously is pretty clear here but
if you have a very long branch a lot of
ifs and stuff it's quite easy to forget
to assign to it and that can cause a bug
in fact it probably has caused in
foreign bugs and then what happens if
there's an else brush you haven't even
thought about that right what happens to
the value of result on the ailes case
and then finally because results outside
the if statement it's a side-effect and
you can't means you can't take this if
statement and refactor it you can't pull
it out as an extract method so that's a
problem now if you write the same thing
using the ternary operator which C has
it's one of the few kind of expression
things that C languages have the result
variables assigned after I don't have to
kind of declare it first and assign
after it is assigned and declared at the
same time and so I never have to worry
about what is the default what is the
initial value when I haven't assigned it
because it can't happen similarly I
can't forget to assign it because all
the branches return something and I just
assign the whole thing to the turn monie
and in a ternary expression you have to
have an else case you can't say well if
it's true do this but if it's false I
don't know you always have to handle
both cases so you're never going to
forget something and because there's no
side-effects in that little like the
ternary expression I can take that turn
expression and literally refactor it I
can pull it out into its own little sub
expression like that now obviously this
is a super trivial case but in
expression based languages which most
functional languages are and sequel is
this kind of refactoring this kind of
not having to worry about things that
can go wrong is really natural and it's
a shame that it's not more common in
other languages so expressions are great
because they reduce bugs and they make
refactoring easier so another tick
another important thing about sequel as
a sort of design lesson is its
declarative you don't tell Segal how to
do something you tell it what you want
to do so let's say I want to find all
the people older than 50 or whatever now
if you do the whole program you're going
to have to like open a file read through
all the rows you try to find the thing
there's a lot of stuff you know that
buries what you're actually trying to do
now if you look at the sequel equivalent
you just say you know selects people
where the age is greater than 50 I don't
care whether you have to open a file to
do that I don't really know I don't want
to know how you do it behind the scenes
I just want to know you know what I want
to do I'm telling you what I want to do
and one bonus about this approach is
that performance is independent of the
query so if this is a slow query I can
just add an index I can tune it without
having to rewrite my code if I go back
to the C kind of code and I say well
this is slow if I want to tune it I have
to rewrite this code and I have to start
you know maybe inline the loops or do
some things I have to change what I do
in order to get performance so my code
has to change which is a chance for it
to break with sequel you know the is
orthogonal the that what you want to do
and how you do it are completely
separately that's a really good design
lesson if you ever designing api's make
sure you focus on the what are not the
how and finally sequel has separation of
concerns we're always told don't mix
different things together sequel is a
great example of that because it's a
query language right so it does select
and it has where right now if you want
to do an insert an update that's a
different language that's the data
manipulation language and they're
different languages I mean they they
look like they're all in one pile but
they're actually you know different
languages they're defined differently
and then if you want to define tables
and stuff that's another language now we
do think of sequel meaning all these
things together but technically they are
different things and the first one the
data query language is the one that's an
expression based language so keep your
concerns separate don't try and mix them
up it makes it it makes implementation
easy and you get a lot of benefits from
doing that okay so be particular if you
ever designing a lot of these things
obviously you're not designing a program
but if you're designing an API you're
designing interfaces you're designing
just the concept of a system these are
good guidelines be predictable use a
consistent model if you are using a
language try and use an expression based
language it makes your code more
composable and if you're exposing an API
focus on exposing the what not how and
in all your coding please try and
separate your concerns don't mix you
know different things together and
finally sequel is an interactive
language you don't you know when you
want a sequel cuy you don't compile it
and wait 10 minutes and then see what
happens right you can try things out you
can play you can experiment that's
really really important that makes the
language much more attractive to people
so interactivity is something we really
in as humans we love to play with things
so interactivity is really really
important so this is all the stuff we
can learn from a boring language like
sequel only so who thought that sequel
be so interesting well there you go and
especially the expression based stuff
it's really sad that you know the 1970s
we had this figured out and even today
most popular languages are not
expression based and most popular
language do not separate concerns and
most proper languages do not have a
decorative interface and so on and a lot
of them are kitchen-sink languages they
don't have a predictable model it's kind
of sad that we really haven't progressed
that much since the 70s all right now
for the first sort of mind-blowing one
for people who are not familiar with
this as a prologue was the first
mainstream logic programming language as
design in France and it stands for
programming in logic and it was very big
in Europe during the days when AI was
very big in the 70s it was the European
arts Lisp and it's also big in Japan
it's like those pop stars so what can we
learn from Prolog well again Prolog has
a very very consistent model everything
is the fact or a rule and that's pretty
much it so what I mean by a fact so
here's some facts liz is 92 Charles is
69 and so on
and Charles is the parent of wills and
Liz as a parent of Charles so those are
facts they're just like a sequel table
with relationships between the tables
now unlike sequels prologue has rules
which makes relationships so you can say
somebody a person is older than a
particular age if the person has an age
and that age is greater than the age you
pass in and one person is older on
another person if that person first
person has an age the second person has
an age and the first age is bigger than
the second age so those are kinds of
rules you know within prologue that's
part of the database the rules are part
of the database
unlike sequel where you'd have to write
a separate kind of stored product
something this is actually part of the
database so prologue can exploit this
and again prologue is the decorative
thing when I want to do a query I say
you know I can just say what is the age
of this and if it's 92 that's true and
if I say if I say who has the who which
person has age 92 it will basically go
through the list of facts and try and
find someone who has that age and then
it will since I've got this variable P
which is kind of unbound it's a kind of
free variable it will say oh P must be
Liz and that all it will return that
and if I do it backwards if I say what
is the age of Liz and I leave the age
variable kind of unbound it will go
through the list of facts and I say all
this fact matches and we know sine a has
to be 92 so this is it's not a query
it's what they call unification it's
like you've got one thing over here
you've got another thing over here they
must be the same so I will make this
thing be the same as this other thing
over here
unifying the two and what's cool is it
works in both directions and we'll see
an example of them so it's a
bi-directional kind of you don't have to
have queries for this thing and a
different kind of query with this thing
it's the same model all the way through
here's another example is Liz that my
own partner Harry yes because it uses
the rule that I had if someone's a
parent and they're the parents parent
here's another one if IP is unbound it
will figure out who the grandparent is
so this is an example of using the list
of rule facts but it's also using the
rule that I said that the grandparent
is the parent of a parent and so on so
forth okay so a lot of people would say
you know this is kind of cool this is
kind of my sequel they could do kind of
query language like this and the answer
is yes in fact there is a query language
based on Prolog and it's called data log
and let me give you an example so here's
a kind of really complex query get me
the names and addresses of employees who
work for at least one project located in
Houston but whose Department does not
have a location in Houston now you
better set up the wall say that if a
manager works on a project and the
project is based in Houston then that's
one thing and then if a manager has a
department and the department is not in
Houston that's another thing and then
finally you see it hit me the first
middle last and address of an employee
who has a manager and the manager works
on this project and the managers know in
Houston so this is actually a database
query and it looks very much like Prolog
you're basically filling in various
slots so you don't have to write any
joins I mean if you try to write this in
sequel that'll be a lot of really
complicated joins going on behind the
scenes and you wouldn't really be sure
that you've got it right the either with
the with the Prolog style you just fill
in the slots or the things and you say
well this thing this manager over here
has to be the same as this manager over
here and that unifies and together and
therefore the two things are the same
that's kind of cool all right let's look
at bi-directional unification so Prolog
has a function called append which takes
a list and another list that makes a new
list so if I say what if you take the
list one and you take the list of two
and three and you append them what you
get where you get one two three okay so
that's kind of like a regular function
but what's cool is you can put it
backwards you can say I don't know what
X is if I said that X is something and
you append two and three to it you get
the list one two three what is X and it
says what X must be one so it will work
backwards the same thing it will
actually work backwards and tell you
what you need to do to make this thing
happen or you can be even
ever and you can say well I have two
things X&Y and when I get concatenate
them I want to make a new list one two
three
what are x and y well Prolog will say
well X could be an empty list and Y
could be the list 1 2 3 that would work
and then it will go to the next thing I
said well you could also have X be the
list 1 and Y could be 2 & 3 or X could
be 1 & 2 and y could be 3 or X could be
1 2 & 3 Froelich will actually find all
the different solutions so this same
function can be used in three different
ways it can be used to like to find the
answer there's something would wait how
do I append to lists but it can also be
fine what do I have to do in order to
get this particular result so it's kind
of backtracking its goal seeking so if
you ever used something like in excel or
they have a kind of goal scenario thing
it's exactly that it's like what do I
have to make this to be to match this
thing over here that's really really an
awesome feature so let me quickly demo
throw a log here so this is his mental
database here and I can say there we go
who is the grandparent of Lear's
and the artist wills and if I say is
wills the grand plan that's true whoops
it's a bit of thing so I think really
here and then I say who is the
grandparent of we'll say and it will say
this so well it works in all sorts of
directions now obviously that's a
trivial example but a great example of
how you can do this is something like
Sudoku so Sudoku is a good example of
constraint based programming you have a
system there's certain rules you have to
follow and you're trying to find
something that matches all the rules you
want to find the best answer and this is
obviously Sudoku is arcane but in a lot
of business situations you have exactly
this thing you want to find you know
given this constraint in this constraint
what is the best price that I should
give you know if I have this special
offer and this special offer which that
I sit
to be really kind of complicated logic
now this is Sudoku in Prolog in eight
lines of code okay so you don't tell it
how to solve the problem you say what is
the problem you say okay there there's
an array of rows and there's nine of
them and then each row has the same
length and it also has to be line and
then each row has a set of values and
the values have to be in the set 1 to 9
and then each row all the values in each
row have to be distinct and if you
transpose the rows you get a set of
columns and all the numbers in the
columns have to be distinct and the
final thing is the little squares the
nine little blocks so we're going to
give them names are going to say row is
ABCDE and we're going to say that the
the blocks in the first three rows ABC
have to be different and the blocks in
the third in the second three rows have
to be different in the blocks in the
third row tetrahedral and that is it so
I haven't told Prolog how to solve for
my just set up what the rules are for
the game I know if I go over here and I
say can you solve this problem Prolog
and there it is it sold it so it's
basically applied all those rules and
solve Sudoku for us so and that's really
really cool you know trying to imagine
writing a Sudoku sofa in another
language is very painful and you're not
never going to be sure you've got it
right
all you have to do in Prolog is what to
write down the definition of what of
Sudoku is and they will figure out the
rest and if you have a bad situation
like here in the second one I've got to
ace in the same well okay so that's not
possible that's going to be a bad answer
so I go to Prolog and I say can you
solve problem 2 and it says false ok
there is no solution to that because
it's constraint based so I think you
know this is an example obviously the
Sudoku is is you know a trivial example
but you people use Prolog for things
like medical databases for natural
language processing but also
this was if you have these kinds of
problems any kind of constraint based
solving Prolog that's awesome for that
one so what can we learn about Prolog
well again it's consistent there's only
one way of doing things and further do
you have facts and rules you know you
have a completely predictable Milley you
don't have special edge cases you don't
have weird is all kitchen sink things is
very very straightforward again it's
very decorative you don't tell Prolog
what to do you set up the rules and it
figures it out which is really really a
great way of solving problems
unification is really awesome the fact
you can do bi-directional queries you
can ask you know is this problem
solvable and you know it's the Sudoku so
problem solvable I could ask is it true
or false and also if I if I have some
left things back I can say well which
things match these slots in order to
make everything work again and again
it's interactive I can play with it
interactively I can experiment so if you
ever write a rules engine don't if you
ever do any complex business rules you
know consider using Prolog you can slot
it in it's got an API you can call it
from other languages definitely worth
checking out all right and now next one
ml so M L stands for meta language
written in 1973 or so or started all
these states are very fuzzy you know
they kind of start writing it and then
it doesn't really take the world to
become stable so I don't think it was
really stable unto the end of the 70s
but designed as part of a theorem
proving system so it's got this kind of
logic thing again not to be confused as
machine learning obviously it's an
impure function language pretty much the
first mainstream function language and
it's the parent of a whole branch of
function languages including standard ml
Oh Carolyn F sharp there's another
branch represented by Haskell which
comes from Aranda which is a slightly
different kind of history there all
right now ml is a functional programming
language I'm not going to talk about
functional programming because we've
already talked enough about fashion for
a moment so I'm going to talk about
other things that ml and teachers which
is nothing to do with functional
programming so the first things that ml
had
which is really cool is type influence
so let me explain how type inference
works for people who aren't familiar
with it and it's type of emphasis uses
pretty much the same router with as
prologues unification it's like I have
this thing has been int and I don't know
what this thing is therefore this thing
has to be in it so it's kind of making
them be the same thing so let's look at
example here's a function does something
I don't care what there were two
parameters f of X and I haven't told you
what type they are I haven't got any
types in there whatsoever so can the
type inference the thing figure out what
those types are without me saying what
they are well the answer is yes you can
and the first thing it does is it says
well X must be an int because you're
adding it to one and one's an int X mice
or subunits okay and then it says the
same thing if you're adding Y to hello
then y must be a string so now we know
that X is an int and Y is a string and
then we look at this function and the
input of this function is now an integer
we know that because it's X and the
output of this function is y so it must
be a string so this function must be
something that turns integers into
strings so now we know what that
function is and now we know everything
about the the type we can say there's a
function parameter which is an int
string function the X parameter is going
to be an integer and the final return
value is going to be hello plus y and we
know that's a string so the type
inference algum has figured all this
stuff out without us having to tell it
and so this kind of this code up there
kind of looks like a scripting language
it looks like Python or Ruby or
something but it's actually statically
typed you don't have to you know you get
all the benefits of type checking
without all the overhead of having to
tell the compiler all the time
now you think it was just okay this is a
trivial example why is it really
important here's a more complex version
this is C sharp for the link methods
called
route by
now I challenge you to understand what
is going on you have an enumerable which
contains a grouping which contains a
tiki and a tea sauce and so on could you
write this type signature yourself I
mean maybe some people could but you
know it's complicated now in F sharp the
same code looks like this you've grouped
by you know you have a source and you
have a key select another F sharp
compiler will do type inference and it
will fill all this stuff out for you so
you know you don't have to try and
figure this stuff out so the thing about
type inference is it's obviously it's
less typing you don't have to type all
the the words in but more importantly is
less noise there's more more focus on
logic and less focus on kind of fluff
all this type stuff kind of gets in the
way I don't really care what the types
are I just want it to work the type
checker will make sure that I don't make
a mistake okay another important thing
about ml which is kind of a little minor
thing but I think it's actually not so
minor different defaults so in ml based
languages things that are mutable by
default and if you want mutability as a
special case now that's the completely
opposite of most kind of see like
languages where mutability is that
default and if you want immutability you
have to do a lot of extra work things
are non null by default and if you want
null ability that's a special case
that's again the exact opposite of most
c-like languages you get structural
equality by default if you have two data
structures they're going to be equal by
default if they have the same values so
all that all that time we've written you
know get your overwriting equals and
overwriting hash code and stuff you
don't have to do that if you want
reference equality you can do that
that's a special case and all the data
structures have to be initialized you
can never have uninitialized values
that's the default again so you never
have accidentally no you know very
accidental things that you forgot to
handle so even these simple defaults
actually can make a really really big
difference in and how useful the
programming languages right number three
algebraic type system and as I prefer to
call it a composable type system and if
you went to my talk earlier on
the power of composition this is the
same little bit I'm going to repeat here
so what I mean by a composable time
system in ml languages the types are
don't have behavior it's a function
language there's no behavior with the
types it's just data so the good thing
about that is because they're just data
you can glue them together because you
don't have to worry about or the
behaviorism and you can glue them
together in two different ways you can
add them together and you can or them
together and what do I mean by that okay
well anding is something we're all
familiar with oh if I say I want a fruit
salad it's an apple and a banana and a
cherry that is basically a record type
or a pair or a tuple you know things
you're very familiar with in F sharp it
looks like this this is very similar to
how you do it in c-sharp or JavaScript
or something it's just basically a
record structure or any you know the
rule for any width so nothing special
there but the other thing which is ml
languages have is composing with aw so
if I say a snack is an apple or a banana
or cherry this is the kind of thing
that's not so easily available in most
modern languages in f-sharp you do I
fact this you say it's an apple or
banana or a cherry now it's sort of like
an enum sort of or sort of like sub
classing sort of normally it's a
different concept and it's a really
fantastic concept and we'll see in a
minute these are called I like to call
them the choice types because the choice
of different things
they're called discriminated unions they
were also called some types lost doesn't
words for these things but really really
a valuable thing once you have this
thing in your toolkit it's really hard
to go to a language which doesn't have
it so let's look at a real world example
let's say that we have three forms a
payment we want to take cash checking
cards and for cheques we need extra
information and for cards we need some
extra information so how would you
implement this well in our way you might
have an interface and subclasses and so
on in an algebraic tie system you build
up the model using types by building
smaller types and bigger type building
bigger types as well
just like Lego so you start off with
some small primitive type like this
check number and a card number okay
they're primitives and then you say okay
the card type is a choice between Visa
and MasterCard and credit card
information is an and it's a credit it's
a car type and the card number okay so
it's a record structure so we've got a
choice using or and we've got a record
using hand okay now we've built up some
more types let's use those we can say
okay payment method is a choice it's
either cash or cheque and if it is a
check we have the check number or it's a
card and if it's a card we have some
extra card information that's a choice
type and then we can build on that and
we can say okay we need a payment amount
that's a decimal a currency as a choice
so another primitive another choice and
then we can build on that and we can say
a payment is an amount and it's a
currency and it's a method so we've
actually built quite a big domain in a
few lines of code right there's the
final ones of record type this thing of
building bigger types and small types
really really powerful concepts and this
is one of the really nice things about
algebraic type system and if you do this
you get this kind of thing as types as
documentation something we're always
trying to go for right types as
executable documentation so this is a
bunch of types and I think you can
understand you know what this is about
there's nothing to have playing a cards
is a card game right just from that just
from the way the types look you can
guess what it does and types can be
nouns but they can also be verbs you can
have function types say this is how you
deal this is how you pick up a card so
you've basically got the entire domain
on one screen you don't have to go to 20
different files into 20 different
classes try and figure out what the
domain is
in a functional language you typically
have this as the first file in your
program and all the rest of server uses
this as the basis of its implementation
and what's nice about this is that even
a non-technical developer can look at
this code and understand it so if I show
this to a non-technical person I say
what payment methods are accepted you
know they don't have to be a programmer
they can probably look at this and tell
me and if they say well you forgot to
handle PayPal or something they can look
at this and give me some feedback that's
really nice if you're doing domain
driven design or something like this
you're working with domain experts this
is a fantastic way of work doing this so
obviously a massive topic I have a whole
talk about this and I have a whole book
about this so if you want more about
this going with my book alright I'm not
going to do a demo of ml because there's
been a lot of F sharp demos at this
conference I highly recommend Thomas
better checks demo of how to build Excel
in an hour and there's a lot of other
good toss there this conference that you
can see right what can we learn from ml
its expression based again everything is
composable you can take ml expressions
and build big expressions from small
ones this composability thing hop on
over and over again we've got composable
expressions we've got composable types
building bigger things some small things
like Lego is a really really powerful
principle type inference is absolutely
awesome and any language that doesn't
have type inference is a loser seriously
just making the defaults different if
you can and they kind of surprise
obviously you're not writing programming
languages but if you're ever designing
anything think about what the defaults
are makes make sure the defaults make it
hard to do bad things so make sure that
the false you know always work so if we
stop having a mutability by default it's
really helpful if you want mutability
fine you can answer it but it's not the
default thing make the default thing the
good thing ml was the first language to
juice parametric polymorphism which we
call generics and incredibly even in the
current era we have some language we do
not have generics mentioning their names
algebraic types are awesome yeah going
back to type refers you know Java
developers just got var right very very
simple type emphasis and people are
freaking out over it that dude this has
been around for 40 years okay and
algebraic types been around for 40 years
and people don't even have them know
most languages it's like what are we
what are we even doing right and now
small talk so I heart small talk I love
small talk it was my first love as it
were and I've still lost a lot
very much develop a desert spark
so it's part where they did everything
they invented the PC the first GUI the
first laser printer they invented the
Ethernet they did everything they're
pretty amazing
and when they introduced small talk it
was the first message based our it they
introduced model-view-controller they
had a full IDE on a graphical user
interface back in the 1970s it had a
virtual machine and had a generational
garbage collector really incredible so
galaxy bring many many galaxy brains to
small talk for being awesome this is
what the Smalltalk user interface looked
like back in the 80s
no sorry back in yeah back in the
natives with a Mac anybody hasn't
changed since then and you'll see in a
minute that is pretty much the same
interface so I'm going to do a small to
demo because I can't really no point
even showing you the code but small talk
has a consistent model like all the
other ones we talked about everything's
an object everything is an object
everything isn't objects I cannot stress
this highly enough everything everything
isn't objects
it's got minimal syntax it has three key
words and it has three kinds of messages
and that is it so everything is done
through the language so for example
there's no if statements and there's no
for loops in small talk everything has
done through messages now if you put
example at a modern example this is how
a sync was done in c-sharp versus
f-sharp so in c-sharp they just added a
sync a while ago and they had an add a
new keyword for a sync I had to change
the language to do a sync an F sharp F
sharp that's a facility for doing things
like that and they could just add it as
a library the language is already
powerful enough to add a sync as a sort
of library and that's one of the
differences between making a powerful
language and a language where you have
to keep changing the syntax all the time
the other thing about small talk people
aren't really used to either which is
the whole kinds of late binding so late
binding means that you don't really do
anything to the very very last minute
and you can intercept a message at any
point up to the last point and like work
with it change it route it so you're
going to be a dynamic language like
Python or Ruby
be a really dynamic language I mean
really go whole hog and be as dynamic as
you possibly can and small talk is
really the ultimate
language and another interesting about
small talk no text files everything is
in memory all the time and which means
that everything is already there every
single file at me every single class
every single objects always in memory
all the time and you might think well
that's a lot of memory it's like no it's
a lot less memory than a tab in chrome
you know it's tiny 2 gigabytes
maybe I mean I worked on a small to
image that was 2 megabytes back in the
80s you know it hasn't changed that much
so let's do a small talk demo and here
we go
right so here is an integer
42 and maybe a bit bigger and you can
send it messages like hex what is your X
well it's 2a and then I can say you know
add yourself to a float view point to
when it prints out 45 so you can see
that it's all very interactive the
answers actually show on the screen
right next to this so I can actually use
the answers so it prints the answers
right next to what you're doing so this
is what you call the keyword message
where you have a parameter something
like X is a as a as a you know a message
with no parameters and then of course
you can have binary messages and that is
it that's the entire small-tooth message
passing system small talk is kind of
cool there's no surprises and small talk
if I say what is 1/2 small top says it's
1/2 if I say what is 1/2 plus 1/3 it
says 5/6 ok so fractions are built in
the idea is you don't don't have to know
about floating-point and you don't have
to know about what the max inches I mean
here's another good example if I say 42
factorial and we're going to get a over
flow no I'm going to get a very large
number back so you know it doesn't the
whole point it hides it's an interface
you white why should you know I want you
to care what the max inches you know
it's not relevant to your programming
you focus on what the bill is
so everything everything is an object
now if I want to do this Lake binding
thing if I say hello to 42 it will say
small integer does not understand hello
right now I could say okay maybe I made
a mistake well maybe I do want to make
you know so what I go is I go into the
debugger and rather than saying oh I
made a mistake I'm just going to define
a new method right now hello okay and
I've saved it now I'm in the debugger I
just edited some code this is this Lake
binding thing the code hasn't finished
executing yet so now I can carry on
executing with my new method and now it
works so I've actually interrupted the
code written some new code and kept
going all the same time and it's
actually really common in small talk to
write code in the debugger you basically
might have methods it doesn't work you
just type it in until it does work find
go to the next thing where it doesn't
work and you keep typing so you
literally can code in the debugger you
don't because there's no files it's like
which file did I have to put this in I
know I don't care it's not a file based
system I didn't have to define you know
a new file for this particular method or
anything um if I want to create a new
thing let's say I have an animal I want
to create a new animal in a in a object
onto language you know you might say
something like this right there's no
constructors in small talk how do you do
how do you make a new object in small
talk you send a methods
you mean you send a message so I have to
send a message animal as a thing it's a
class I send it a message if I want a
new animal I say cat and now it says I
can't all right so everything everything
is an object so classes object so if I
say 42 what is your class it says I'm a
small integer okay now in c-sharp and
Java classes are not the same thing you
know there's no you have things like
static methods there's no static methods
in Smalltalk everything is an object
so the class is an object and you can
talk to the class you can say hello
class
what is your class and says I'm the
class of small integer so that's the the
kind of static the methods you know the
parent class the small integer okay
hello small integer class what is your
class and class metaclass hello magic
floss
what is your class I'm at a class class
and so on and so forth and actually at
that point you get in to leave the class
of metaclass is is a squirrel skin but
the thing is that everything isn't
object and I can just browse it there's
a browser everywhere I can go straight
to a particular browser and now browsing
metaclass if I go to a 42 class here and
I browse it and I'm looking at small
integer which is a subclass of integer
which is a subclass of floats which is
some type of arithmetic value and so on
here's all the methods down here so this
is a full IDE and at any point there's
no sir you know this is the source code
there's no text file so I literally I
can I can just change this code right
now and save it and you know I don't
have to worry about this all the stuff
gets in the way the whole thing of text
files that's nothing through the
programming that's just overheads if I
want to do programming and just type
some stuff and it works that's
programming okay so if you want object
or engine program
now here's another question for you
let's go to the animal class now let's
say I don't like animal I want to create
a new kind of animal how do I create a
new kind of animal do wage create a
class definition somewhere no I send a
message to somebody
everything is sending the message who do
I send a message to and I send a message
to object so this actually is a message
it's a message with five different
parameters so this is the name of the
sub class this is what the instant
variables are class variables and so on
if I send a message to object and I say
actually I want to I want to send this
message sub class anymore - okay and I'm
gonna do it and all of a sudden there it
is I've got a new
[Music]
I've got a new class right there and if
I want to add a new instance variable I
just send the same message again and
then we just uh there you go so now I've
got a name and an age so everything is
sending messages like I say everything
is an object there's nothing which is
not an object the compiler is an object
the stack traces an object the entire
thing isn't object in fact if I just if
I do the debugger is an object
everything is an object really really is
object-oriented in the most literal
sense one final thing is let's look at
if true and if false I said there were
no control statements so how do I do if
true false if there's no control
statements in the language well I send
it a message of course that's the right
answer to everything so let's say one
equals one that's going to be true and I
send it a message and I say if true or
false and like this so these things this
is a message with two parameters that's
the first private there's the first part
of the message there's a second part
message and these parameters are blocks
you can think of them almost like
lambdas in in in other languages it's
basically a thing to run so if I say if
I do that it says yes and if I say is 2
equal to 1 and I said you know now it
lets me look let's look up the
implementation of if true if both and it
turns out there were three in from our
three implementations of it whether we
notice that I can I'd have to worry
about you know you talk about browsing
source files and stuff and finding
things in an ID small source had this
again since the 80s you just go straight
to the definition straight to the
references so there are three
definitions one is for boolean and the
billion definition says subclass
responsibility meaning I don't care not
my problem
there are then other ways not it was is
there a there's a class called true and
there's a class called false and they
are separate classes so the true the
false class it implements this
how does it implements it it just takes
the false part the lambda that sort
passed in the blocks the faster and it
just runs it and if you go to the
information of true it just takes the
true thing that's passed in and runs it
so this is just a message like I say
there is no true false statement
everything is done through messages so
you don't that is why the syntax are so
normal literally only three keywords and
everything behave if you have a very
very powerful concept and you you really
take it to the max you can do incredible
things right that is enough small talk
lets me go back to my presentation okay
so what can we learn from small talk a
really really consistent model
everything is an object everything is a
message you know that's it once you
understand that everything is an object
and everything is a message you can you
understand everything that's not oh
really that's it very very minimal
syntax making the powerful language so
rather than hacking around with special
edge cases like we need there so we
dislike no you design it so you can do
anything in the language and be awesome
the people I mean this is not a joke the
people who design small talk were trying
to make it awesome and they were trying
to make people fall in love with it they
spend a lot of time with this kind of
stuff same thing like the early people
who did the Mac you know they spent a
lot of time making cute icons and stuff
they really really cared about the user
experience which is why people did fall
another some talking people did fall in
love with the Mac it's really important
this kind of stuff you know making
people fall in love is actually a very
important goal all right so a small talk
is a lot of people say well small
thought was cool it's kind of a dead end
it's all kind of interactive thing no
text files
you know it's interactive it's
self-contained it doesn't talk to the
outside well what kind of you know
that's really a dead end for Pokemon
languages so let's talk about language X
which squeak tendinitis mu9 so in the
1980s people would literally pay
thousands of dollars to use this
language all right
literally thousands of dollars and the
descendants of this language have been
incredibly
they really at the heart of the dominant
software fellows okay any ideas what I'm
talking about and its grandchild I would
say is the most popular programming
language in the world yes the answer is
what language am I talking about I'm
talking about VisiCalc okay visicalc
basically drove the PC industry people
would spend $5,000 to buy an apple an
apple - so they could run this account
and then VisiCalc forget Lotus 1-2-3
which is the most popular software of
the 80s and then Lotus 1-2-3 began Excel
which is the most popular software of
the 90s and the 2000s on this is really
incredibly powerful okay and what is so
important about visicalc is it's got a
consistent model okay it's a programming
language it's not just so you it's not
just an application as a programming
language it's got a consistent model
like Smalltalk it's got a highly
interactive environment and it's got a
pro language and they all fit together
really nicely now if you took away the
programming language it wouldn't work
the whole thing is you can program
formulas there little tiny formulas but
they're still formulas it's a program
language it's a very domain-specific
programming language it's all about one
thing how do you work with a spreadsheet
it's expression based okay everything
returns every form returns and you think
it doesn't set variables and it's
something that non-programmers going to
understand they can understand a 1 plus
B 2 ok anyone could write that it's
functional you can do these things like
sum all the numbers from this to this as
these functions built-in and there's you
program by filling in slots you don't
think you're programming you're filling
in this formula here in this formula
here there's no text files you don't
have to write this text file you
basically fill in all the slots and like
Prolog you kind of map they magically
kind of unify this like you put this one
here this one here this one gets filled
in automatically so there's a lot of
things that visicalc kind of took from
these other previous languages which is
really you know very useful so what can
we learn from VisiCalc um programming is
not just writing text files in in C like
language there's more to programming
their programming is getting computer to
do what you want and Excel is a phat
example there's more people using a cell
than right
any kind of regular programming language
so it's not just programmers people love
to interact and explore okay this whole
thing of making people wait
making people comprise life
interactivity is really fantastic way
and programming of a specific domain is
actually much more important than for a
general-purpose programming okay
you know Excel it isn't he trying to
write if you try to do Excel kind of
stuff in a general pattern language it
would be horrible the very fact is it's
very specifically designed for that one
particular purpose and that was that's
what's making it great so use the right
tool for the job don't use a hammer
you know oh we do use a hammer if it's
the right tool job but don't always use
a hammer for everything so there are
many different approaches to solving
problems it's a good idea to have a big
tool boss okay
don't just think I know c-sharp I know
Java I know JavaScript go and learn APL
don't learn Prolog go alone something
you'll help your mind expand and also
please see style syntax is not the only
syntax in the world I hear people say I
can't read a language doesn't have curly
braces okay all these languages know
these languages have curly braces they
all had by the way they all had periods
at the end of a sentence like proper
grammar okay
small talk uses periods Prolog uses
periods this whole thing of using
semicolons to end a sentence you know
English teacher would be very upset with
you know curly braces anywhere and no
dot syntax so small talk the object in
our language doesn't have dot syntax
okay it says it has messages so going
back to this quote a language that
doesn't affect the way you think about
program is not worth knowing so go forth
and expand your galaxy brain don't learn
some new languages and have fun all
right thanks very much
and I'll put these slides are my website
on for 4:40 and there's more functional
programming in this room the rest of the
conference so have fun thanks very much